c'est un peu comme s'il dansait le
tisserand et son métier ne font plus
qu'un guillaume est concentré à
l'extrême sur le motif qu'il a créé et
savoure de le voir naître sous ses
doigts
[Musique]
disposition artistique et envie de créer
du lien on fait naître ce projet
d'atelier ouvert au public que Guillaume
espère pouvoir finaliser dans cette
vieille ferme grâce au financement
participatif chambre et tableau d'hôtes
devraient t'ouvrir en même temps
je sens que l'idée d'avoir un atelier
qui soit ouvert à la visite ça va plaire
forcément parce que j'ai plein de
questions sur mon travail et les gens
vraiment se posent beaucoup de questions
sur le métier de tisserand donc
forcément ça devrait plaire et puis faut
pas oublier que voilà sur les montagnes
du Jura on a un peu moins de neige
l'hiver parfois de la pluie l'été et on
a besoin d'occuper aussi nos touristes
ben quand la météo n'est pas favorable
dès aujourd'hui et grâce à la
mondialisation des réseaux le travail
d'exception du Tisseron français à des
adeptes bien au-delà de la région sa
deuxième vie sera la bonne il en est sûr